three one zero ignition lifting off and
launching towards a new chapter in the
space race the final test of the space
x-craft seconds in and at supersonic
speeds the abort is triggered
Michael Kerrigan launch escape initiated
starting crustose which propel the
capsule aware
you can hear some royal moments later
the rocket breaks up and there they are
drogue chutes are out in the capsule
parachutes to safety this is hugely
significant a successful test will mean
that that's really the last hurdle for
spacex in sending humans into space and
the next time we see these images and
that splashed down on the crew dragon
there will be US astronauts on board
catastrophic failure is a scenario NASA
never wants to see but it has to be
tested before people are put on board
one former astronaut who's flown for
missions says it's a major milestone the
US has been unable to launch our own
spectra knots into space since 2011 when
we retired the space shuttle so it's
been nine years coming up on ten years
since we've had that capability and so
this is a big deal SpaceX is owned by
billionaire Elon Musk his company
working with NASA to fly astronauts to
and from the International Space Station
this could now happen within months a
giant leap for NASA and a pivotal point
in space exploration
Laura bundok Sky News